We actually have increasingly good news to
report about what's happening with coronavirus
vaccination in the United States and in some
other countries, but with most of our audience
in the U.S., we're going to look at US data
today.
And you would think everybody would be thrilled
about this.
But there's actually some people who are furious
at the number of vaccinations happening in
the number of vaccinations that will soon
be taking place.
But we'll get to that a little bit later in
the show.
You might remember that last week and not
this past weekend where we changed the clocks,
but last weekend we had a record seven million
or so vaccinations in three days.
That was the best three day period to date.
We blew that out of the water this past weekend
with eight point eight million vaccines injected
on Friday, Saturday and Sunday, by far a new
record.
Now, this does include what is essentially
a massive dump of vaccine data.
On Saturday, it made it look like there were
four and a half million vaccinations done
just on that day.
In reality, there was a change to the methodological
data and in reality that four point five million
would be kind of spread out over a few days,
which is why we're saying eight point eight
million vaccines over three days now pushing
us to an average of about two point four million
vaccines per day over the last week.
I think we're on the way to 2.5 million a
day.
I think we're on the way to three million
a day.
The question is more, will we get to three
and a half or how much can we really do?
But this is looking increasingly good right
now.
The states with the highest percentage of
people fully vaccinated are Alaska at 18 percent.
New Mexico, it's 17 percent.
South Dakota and West Virginia at 15 percent.
And then you've got a bunch of states at 14
percent, a bunch more at 13 percent.
The states doing the worst with vaccination
as a percentage of the population are Utah
at only eight percent, followed by Washington,
D.C..
Not a state I know, but it's still on our
list.
Tennessee, California, Georgia, Texas.
And then you've got a few states at 10 percent.
Now, the reality is that with Alaska and New
Mexico as outliers at the very top, the states
doing great are at 13 to 15 and the states
doing poorly are at eight to 11.
So like the range is relatively tight and
it has to do with a number of different factors,
including distribution of doses, rural versus
urban nature of each state.
And over time, these numbers are going to
go up and they're going to go up more quickly.
Now, Dr. Anthony Fauci suggested over the
weekend on CNN, keep vaccinating as quickly
as possible, but keep measures in place because
some of the things that are starting to happen,
including in Florida, another spring break,
destinations are not quite so good.
But let's take a look.
The best way that we can avoid any threat
from variance is due to things get as many
people vaccinated as quickly as we possibly
can and to continue with the public health
measures until we get this broad umbrella
of protection over society that the level
of infection is very low.
You know, there's a tenet in virology that's
so true, Jake, and that is viruses don't mutate
unless they replicate and replication means
it's spreading around in the community, if
you can blunt that, usually blunting the evolution
of mutants for sure.
So, Dr. Fauci, of course, absolutely correct.
And we'll talk about the spring break stuff
a little bit in a moment.
What new information do we have about the
impact of vaccines?
Well, we know that so far coronavirus cases
have fallen 80 percent among U.S. nursing
home staff and residents.
They were of the first groups of people to
be vaccinated.
That's very good.
We know we're heading to full adult vaccine
eligibility across the United States.
Everyone 18 plus will be eligible for a vaccine.
Appu Joe Biden's announcement on Thursday
night on May 1st or sooner.
Some states ready to move even sooner.
That's just six weeks away at the latest.
That's fantastic.
We know, thanks to really detailed Israeli
data, that of the people recently hospitalized
there, only eight percent had been vaccinated,
74 percent of those hospitalized had no vaccine,
and the remainder, about 18 percent, were
between dose one and two, not yet at full
vaccine power.
That is reassuring data.
But we also know that tons of people are going
nuts and even absent being vaccinated.
Ted are starting to ignore all safety measures,
Florida, for example, becoming and absolutely
out of control spring break situation with
Marcellus people all over the place as if
nothing is going on now that we shouldn't
do this.
This is a major problem.
My guess is that if you start having young
people go nuts but continue vaccinating those
most at risk, you'll still get a ton of cases.
But you should see fewer hospitalizations
and deaths because the people going bonkers
on South Beach are primarily younger folks
who will not statistically get serious cases.
Some will and some will die, though.
But the most the most moral the most logical
thing to do would be let's keep up the guidelines
for just a little bit longer because we are
starting to get their case.
Declines have slowed down a bit.
Death declines continue to go relatively quickly
and we'll have updated numbers about that
tomorrow.
But what we have to talk about next is you
would think there's no way to spend more vaccinations
as anything other than a fantastic thing.
But there are right wingers really angry at
how many people are now getting vaccinated
under the new protocol of the Biden administration.
And we're going to
talk about
that next.